- My knowledge of Hannukah
is the Disney Channel movie
Full-Court Miracles.
- What I know vaguely about the story
I learned from the Rugrats.
- I know that there's a Menorah.
- You'd have to have letters
that make "kha, kha!"
- C, H.--
- H, A.--
- U, N.--
- I, K, Haunik, A.
- K.
- A.
- Hannukah celebrates...
- Was it when they were,
crossing the Red Sea?
- They only had a little bit of oil.
- And, through the miracle of the Lord,
that oil lasted eight nights.
- That's why everything is fried, I think,
and why potato pancakes
are the love of my life.
- Oh my God, I don't even
know how many days it is.
- It's like seven days, right?
- I think it's eight days of Hanukkah.
- There are twelve candles in a Menorah.
- There are nine candles on the Menorah.
- 'Cause I think it's one
for every day of the week.
- Because there's one for every night
and then there's the one master candle
that you use to light
all of the other ones.
- What's a dreidel, I don't know.
- Don't know what it means.
- Dreidels are big spoons
that Jewish people use
to collect matzo balls out of the pot.
- You spin the dreidel
and then what it falls on,
you have to do what it says?
- You get chocolate coins if you win.
- You win, or you lose,
or you take another turn,
or you take the other guys coins.
- I just remember Jewish friends
getting presents all week.
- Everybody drinks Manischewitz.
- Maybe they have a Hanukkah
party at the end of it?
- They sit around in a circle
and they play the guitar.
- And I think they leave
a seat open for Elijah.
- And Adam Sandler is
leading the ceremony.
(upbeat music)